ce matin-là ce petit groupe perdue dans
l'immensité de l'église saint-andré de
châteauroux va avoir le privilège de
découvrir le premier des deux tableaux
restaurés du peintre joseph bernard
vente un artiste nordiste du xviiie
siècle qu'il a été prix de rome en 1715
et il a eu beaucoup beaucoup pas d'offre
d'aspiration religieuse à lille dans un
inventaire de 1750 on peut dénombrer
presque 400 tableaux dans son atelier
l'oeuvre est magnifique de l'avis de
tous il était difficilement imaginable
d'en voir les potentialités accroché
dans l'une des chapelles le repos de la
sainte famille et son pendant le mariage
de la vierge dont la restauration
comment ce sont des oeuvres importantes
même le support utilisé en attestent
là on est en face de deux tableaux qui
chacun font 12 mètres carrés et qui sont
absolument sans couture ce qui au xviiie
est une chose tout à fait exceptionnel
je n'en avais jamais vu même au 19ème
vous avez des tableaux qui sont comme
celui de saint marcel centaines de
morceaux
le restaurateur a choisi d'effectuer son
travail in situ en raison de la grandeur
des toiles et pour être sûr de les
altérer le moins possible la deuxième
oeuvre a plus souffert que la première
pour l'heure la première étape devrait
permettre d'affiner le diagnostic les
nécessaire d'enlever la crasse c'est à
dire que tout ce qui est sur la couche
picturale
c'est à dire les petits champignons des
taches blanches que vous voyez
et puis les saletés mouche bien sûr
toutes ces petites choses qui se sont
accumulées sur la couche peter le fil
des ans
l'histoire de ces deux toiles commence à
se dévoiler de source sûre on sait que
le général bertrand à qui elle avait été
offert pour son mariage
les a données au couvent des cordeliers
elles ont été transférées et installé
dans l'église saint-andré dans deux
chapelles bien plus tard inscrite à
l'inventaire supplémentaire des
monuments historiques
cette situation pourrait bientôt changer
on va les proposer au classement donc en
commission nationale à paris du fait du
caractère important de ses oeuvres pour
l'art du xviiie siècle français pour la
peinture française du xviiie siècle
ils sont très beaux ils sont très bien
conservés et maintenant on connaît leur
historique
ce sont des tableaux inédits donc il
mérite vraiment d'être porté à la
connaissance de la commission nationale
qui évaluera l'opportunité de classer
mais je ne me fais pas de souci ce qui
reconnaîtra ainsi leur valeur pour le
pays entier pas seulement pour la ville
de châteauroux même si celle ci en
demeure propriétaire est responsable de
la revalorisation
pour la petite histoire il aura fallu 24
ans pour que ces oeuvres repéré par le
responsable de la conservation des
antiquités et objets d'art directeur des
archives départementales de l'époque
marc du pouget et les érudits locaux
soit enfin sauvé de l'anonymat en 2014
le conseil de quartier du centre-ville
apporté son soutien et la municipalité
de châteauroux mettait en oeuvre avec la
direction régionale des affaires
culturelles la restauration des deux
tableaux
[Musique]